guys I am not doing okay if I sound different to you it is
because I knew I forgot to do something or like maybe many
things but one of the things I forgot to do okay let me turn
myself down I'm a all right my audio settings is really not
good at the moment chat it's not i forgot to save my audio
setting i saved the wrong horn i loaded in the wrong
settings so like basically i use Go XLR.
Yeah, because I'm stupid.
And like Go XLR is like the baby mixing thing.
So the thing is, there's two profiles you can save.
And like, so the thing is, there's two profiles you can
save.
Yeah.
So I saved the wrong one.
The profile I saved was the one where like it adjusts the
volume of your stuff.
I didn't realize there's two different profiles
I saved the one where it just gives you the volume like the
set volume not my mic settings so I was like playing around
with my I like the thing is the thing is I didn't up my mic
settings because I did I did the reason being is that I did
thought about it and be like oh what if I fuck up all right
I'm gonna take a screenshot of my mic settings just in case
I am going to take a screenshot but thing is I accidentally
adjusted something on it I accidentally adjusted something
on the setting but then i was like it's okay i'll just like
i'll i'll just like uh delete that profile and then like uh
copy and because i already copied i was like oh that's okay
i copied and paste the profile so they'll like make sure it
like stays the same but i copied and pasted the volume
profile like the fucking the volume profile not the mic
profile so i and not.
Game I didn't screenshotting the settings that I fucked up.
So I was just like, I was just like, oh no.
So I had like a screenshot of like all the mic settings, but
it's the one where I fucked it up.
I don't know which one I fucked up.
I don't know which one I just did.
So like, I sound so weird.
I'm just
I hate the thing is, But, but, no, no, no, no, no.
But the thing is, I still have that profile.
I'm going to have to unplug this PC and plug in my old PC
back so I can grab
my mic profile.
It's good.
I had to unplug it anyway.
I have, the thing is, though, chat, I have to unplug it
anyway because I didn't realize.
The thing is, I didn't realize that...
this pc only has one ssd it only has one driver so because
of because it only has one driver i have to go back to the
store and add another driver if i didn't realize it's only
one driver so yeah it's only one i mean it's free i can't
complain the pc is literally free So I can't complain.
So, like, I have to add another driver in here.
So I'm not risking adding my old drivers to the new one.
Because, like, I don't know what fucked up in my old PC.
This is the thing.
I don't know, like, what it was in my old PC.
That's, like, fucking, like, killing my PC.
Like, I don't know what type of cancer my PC has.
So, like, I'm worried, like, if I, it's, okay, just, like,
think of it, like, I don't know, something terminal.
A PC has something terminal.
And, like, if I bring that terminal disease into my new PC,
it's going to spread to my new PC.
So I need to make sure.
I need to make sure that it doesn't cross paths.
like i don't want to contaminate it so so that is why we
need to contain it into the old body we can't spread it to
this new pc anyways sound guy am i too loud i don't i don't
know i'm using one of the default settings because when i
try to put it okay i'll show you guys what it sounds when i
try to put on my old pc like my default settings save this
one because this was like the only saving grace i have all
right this is basically what i sound like with my old
settings but oh i cut in and out whoa whoa
it's it's not good
so like i don't know what to do
I go back so I don't know I don't know now I'm back I'm back
now that's like I'm a mess guys I'm a mess but at least I
got my new PC before stream started so I win
so in the end I win
I'm sorry!
Ran into windows.
Okay, to be fair, I don't feel like a winner right now.
I don't feel...
To be fair, chat, I don't feel like a winner.
I feel like a mess at the moment.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, thank you for the agenda.
Super, thank you, thank you.
You're not 100% set out at the start of stream beginning.
Hide my simulation.
No, no, no, no.
this is like as best as i could i'm i'm on my only condition
was that to be on my pc i'm on my pc i'm on my new pc they
give them a chance to super thank you thank you all right so
let me tell you the story of everything that happened today
so like um i spent a lot of time by the way I did the file
moving by an external hard drive.
So I did not move.
I did not move my drives because I'm worried that my drivers
were the issue as well.
So I was worried that, like, I don't know when my drivers is
like looking, is like carrying the disease.
So I didn't want to move that into my new PC.
So I moved all like the important files that I need.
which was, okay, to be fair, I also didn't, there was so
many important files.
So, sorry, I meant drives.
Guys, I'm a mess, my brain's not working.
I meant drives.
So, like, basically, I moved all my important files, which
was, like, I don't know, 600 gigabytes of stuff.
I don't know, 600, everything.
You know, like, when you're highlighting and you're like,
you highlight everything, and you're like, everything is
important.
like that's basically it so there's like 600 gigabytes of
files on my uh one terabyte external hard drive so so yeah
so i moved all that then i moved it to their new pc but
thing is before i like i was i brought it out so like you
know how i always said like guys i cannot i cannot move it
i'm worried i can't move it to my new pc because i'm worried
that it's not gonna fit because the
guys i couldn't believe it if the triangular pc fit in the
in the square hole that's crazy guys that was my main excuse
that was my main excuse guys and it actually fit What a
thought.
Guys.
Okay, let me show you guys.
For those who don't follow me on Twitter.
So like.
This is basically.
Alright, here.
Let me get the image out for you guys.
Oh my god.
It's a big image too.
I need to resize it.
I need to resize it real quick.
Alright, so.
Here's the shape.
Here's the PC guys.
So like.
I forgot.
that like on the side I could just slip it in on the side
instead of trying to force I forgot there's a giant hole on
the side
I was I was so focused on the two pillars in the front that
I didn't realize that there was a hole on the side so So I
could just slip it in.
So I learned something new today regarding shapes chat.
Is that crazy?
All right.
So I slipped it off in the whole...
This was like one of the main reasons it took so long
Because I was so worried about it not fitting into the hole
The PC case hole Like the PC hole And like so like that's
why it's been delayed for so long So then when I finally
took it out of the box And like slipped it, like you know
Brought it over I was like wait It actually fit
This is the one of the biggest reasons why I never unpacked
the PC It's because I was worried it wasn't going to fit So
I was like going to try to figure out how to put this PC
into the hole But look guys, it fits Yay!
So yes, after putting it into the hole uh uh another issue
came up apparently uh as i was about i plugged everything in
i realized there was no graphics card in there because the
graphics card was shipped separately so in the so we we got
it out of the hole and i am scared about putting graphics
cards like into a pc i'm really scared about you know this
is a very expensive free pc and i was like you know i
already got this far and i i don't want to break anything so
because like at one point i almost broke the memory stick
well yeah like putting memory sticks into like ram into like
the graphics cards or like into like motherboards and stuff
is so scary like when i had to do it myself so then like
after that i don't like putting parts into PCs anymore
because I almost I almost broke one of the RAM so so like it
so so because of that I don't I don't put put parts into PCs
anymore because I'm worried about breaking a very expensive
PC parts bite size thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you Okie dokie.
I think you need to go back to basic geometry.
How many sides?
It's almost...
It's a triangle!
I don't know what other shape it could be, Chad.
I don't know.
It's definitely not a square.
Alright, anyway.
Anyway.
So, because of that, like, my dad and my mom and dad took it
to the store, like one of the stores near us.
One of the pc repair stores and we're like couldn't and
they're like can you please put the put the graphics card
into the pc and then luckily it got done within like 30
minutes dad brought it back home we put it back we put the
triangle back into the square hole and uh and then you know
we started booting everything up yay it was working things
were like starting to work And then I and then like, you
know, I had to install all the updates and everything and
Oh, yeah, by the way, when we removed the old PC When we
removed the old PC from the box from the square hole, there
was so much dust underneath I like how people are like how
long have you like not cleaned your PC.
I cleaned my PC Like I think like November.
Yeah, November that PC has been was clean in november i know
it's like a long time since november by the way but but it
was clean anyway anyway look anyway um there was so much
dust underneath though it was crazy it was like a lump of
dust so my dad started vacuuming uh vacuuming it all up
before we put the triangle back into the square hole uh i
realized there was like no music playing during my agony
anyway let's have some happy music playing in there just to
feel a little bit better about myself uh
anyway um after oh let me i guess you can still let me put a
tiny version of this here all right so you guys can still
look at chat anyway so after all of that um um As I was
about to, I was plugging in all the slots and everything.
I was plugging in all the slots and everything.
And I realized, why is there only two slots for...
Why is there only two slots for monitors?
That can't be.
Like, even my old PC had, like, four slots for monitors.
So then I was, like, freaking out.
I was like, why is there only two slots?
Like, I was like, there's literally a 40-something in there.
I don't know which one it is.
But there's literally...
I don't know my numbers, but there's literally a 40x in
there.
Like, why?
Why was there only two walls?
And the thing is, it's so...
My desk is, like, up against the...
Almost close to the wall.
It's not up against the wall, by the way.
It's more so of, like, there's two other pillars.
There's two pillars at the end.
So it's very hard to...
like see inside like see deeper inside to be like where the
fuck are the holes because there's like two more pillars at
the end you know so there's two pillars at the end and two
pillars at the front so it's very hard to see deeper to see
where the graphics card is the holes for monitors so i have
to take it out again and i realized you know i didn't
realize this was the thing but there's plugs on a pc i was
like damn they plugged it
But, like, if you guys didn't know, like, newer PC graphics,
like, newer graphics cards have, like, these little, like,
dust plugs, you know?
Like, you know what I'm talking about?
Like, the dust plugs where they cover up some of the holes,
but they don't, so then, like, there was, like, six of them.
So I had to, like, unplug, like, two of them.
And don't laugh at that.
weird um micro chat thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you prove to us that your old pc is clean i mean it's
clean now thank you with the super chat thank you thank you
uh the nemo thank you oh thank you about 20 get the ships
thank you thank you anyway so like i had to you know i was
like freaking out a little bit be like why is there only two
holes like god gave this gpu they god should have given this
gpu more than two holes i'll anyway i should stop um so i
had to take it out of the square hole and like unplug please
don't be loot i'm just talking about the rubber plugs that
help keep dust away what do you want me to say like like how
else do you how else do i sorry my english is like becoming
esl even though english is my first language i went through
a lot today but like What do I say?
It's a dust plug.
Like, oh, sorry, a dust cover?
Like, it's plugging up the hole.
There's no other words for it.
Anyway, as I was saying, I, you know, I took out the dust,
sorry, I removed the dust coverings of the hole.
Is that better?
Why do you want this app to make changes to your okay I
don't know what's me I had something pop up and I said yes
to it I don't know what it was
anyway anyway after uh oh what the fuck oh my god no my
discord notifications are going off too alright after um
after like uh we we did the whole removing the dust
coverings you know I started plugging back in the I started
plugging in back the monitors and everything plugging all
the USBs and all that stuff and then booting the PC on and
then everything all the features downloading and everything
and then I was greeted by Windows 11 I
was greeted with windows 11 i've never ever i've never ever
used windows 11 before so as a windows 10 user for x amount
of years being welcomed by windows 11 and seeing the windows
key in the center
it i was like i hate change why is my windows key in the
center
what is this freak of nature doing there um and then you
know how like windows 11 is like super minimalistic and but
i just oh my gosh i just i can't i it's so hard to deal with
change sometimes Because I'm so used to seeing the same The
same look For like battle explorers And everything So then I
see like I just see like a square With like nothing Or like
nothing on it And I'm just like What the fuck is that?
Where are my bars?
Like where are the Where are the bars To anything?
Why is it just a square?
graphic design is my passion like where is the stuff anyway
it was not a nice sight to see I was not like I already went
through a lot of change right now and then I have to see new
more changes with window 11's interface um so um after that
after you know like being sad about windows 11 where where
is my exactly where is my organized mess where is my trash
can i don't know what the fuck happened to my fucking trash
can that was i was so sad i was so sad i was like where the
hell's the trash can um yes after all of that i had to go
through the whole the sound system and everything but the
one thing that fucked me up during all for this was that my
windows for some reason could not activate like
i i couldn't activate my windows and i don't know what's
going on so so i like messaged hi it and was like hey is
this supposed to happen am i supposed to have like like Am I
supposed to not have, like, pay my own Windows?
I'm so confused.
I was like, I thought I have Windows.
Because I'm clearly in Windows 11.
But, like, you know how they're like, oh, if you don't...
And so I'm like, how is it not...
How is it not activated?
Like, I'm already in the system.
Like, I don't understand.
So, uh, so I was like, hey, um, what's going on?
And they're like, that's weird because it's supposed, you're
supposed to have it activated.
So they gave me like a new key and then they like, they gave
me a new key and I put it in and it gave me an error that
was like, sorry, your hardware changed.
this key because it doesn't work with that key.
I'm like, what does that mean?
What does that?
I was just so confused.
I was like, what does that mean?
What you mean my hardware?
I just got the hardware.
Like, I don't understand.
So, um, so then, so then I was like, that key didn't work.
So then they gave me another key.
And I was like, and they're like, okay, you go to your
PowerShell, whatever.
And then you put this number in.
And I did it and it still didn't work.
So I was like, I don't know what's going on.
I don't know.
I was just like, I don't know what's going on.
I just want to activate my window.
I don't know why why can't the windows be activated I want
to customize stuff so um so like I don't know they like
message me something new but then I was like I'm just gonna
stream I want I need like therapy I mean I shouldn't say
it's therapy because that's fucked up Free therapy for my
dragoons I need my I need like reassurance right now You
guys are like My emotional support animal Right now, like my
emotional support Pet I like I need like some emotional
support Right now Thank you for the super chat Thank you,
thank you I literally had the windows change problem the
other day there's a command in the command prompt you
uninstall it and re-enter the key thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you yeah they they want me to do
something with like command prompts so then i was just like
okay okay i'll do that after the stream i need like i'm like
i'm like mentally up right now from all no i can't even say
that but like i'm i'm like i'm at my
me up i need my emotional support dragons right now um um
like yeah i got mind broken by my own pc anyway anyway um so
we did okay i wrote a list of stuff that happened just in
case so so yeah that's how it all went when it came.
Okay, so I had to install everything again, like OBS, Go
XLR, Steam, almost like everything back up again and putting
all my passwords and everything.
I don't even have majority of the scenes set up.
I just got the starting screen, ending screen, and my
chatting screen.
And that's like everything I've set up so far.
Reaper, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
emotional support books thank you uh vaptin thank you the
super chat thank you thank you build a pc a week ago and had
the same problem woke up one day and it activated it's
because keys are connected to microsoft accounts thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you vaptin that's that's
so fucking stupid why how how so like do i just have to wait
Hyatt bought me two two product keys
wait so like I just have to wait until they accept it oh my
okay well I got two free guys I got two free window keys
okay don't tell Hyatt this but like I don't know if they're
watching but like I freaked out because I was like streams
about to start and I don't know what to do.
And, like, I was, like, really worried that, like, because
at that point, like, it was more so of, like, my Go XLR
wasn't working.
Like, my mic wasn't working.
So then I thought it was something to do with Windows.
So, like, don't tell Hyatt, but I also sort of spent $200
and also bought my own key.
Like, shit.
It's our little secret, guys.
Now we're bonded for life.
You know my deep, dark secret.
Now, so now I have four keys.
You're going to have to keep that secret to your grave.
Glamming, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
key fund guys it's okay it was 200 canadian so that's like
you know a hundred american but yes the key also did not
work by the way so like so like i don't know bill gates is a
little bit it's like now he's a little bit richer now so yay
at least it goes to charity
so um um so yes i i have i have a form four windows 11 keys
now chat yay oh thank you the super chat thank you thank you
thank you dark blade she'd be collecting all the keys like
it's kingdom hearts thank you the super chat dark blade
thank you thank you uh rude thank you the super chat thank
you thank you you figured after using pc for so You become
more tech savvy.
Guess that's not the case.
Here's some for the tech troubles.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But I've been using the same PC for like five years.
I've been coasting.
Guys, I've like used that PC until it literally died.
Like, I've been coasting so hard.
It like had like terminal disease.
And I didn't even try to like save it.
anymore i just let it keep going until like i until it
actually just died like so like what do you mean i should be
more tech savvy i've been fucking coasting the moment it's
at a good stage i just don't care anymore about tech stuff
like i've reached my point i've reached my limit need a this
is why I need a tech guy anyway so that was the story of um
that was the story of new PC and now that we're here I think
it's time that we um oh Panzer thank you for 50 gift and
chips thank you thank you I really appreciate it thank you
Panzer anyway guys now that we're here I think it's time
that we give it a real funeral.
Alright.
Let me...
There you go.
Okay.
So, PC Koon has been with us for so long.
He's been there for, like, since 2019.
And, um... Oh my gosh.
I don't know if I keep this and keep it together, guys.
And PCKoon has been here since 2019.
Oh, shit, wait.
Sorry, PCKoon.
You're dead anyway already.
So, like, people got to see that they donated.
I'm sorry.
Give me a sec, PCKoon.
We're my alerts.
TC Kun, give me a sec.
I need to find my alerts so people can see that they
donated.
Give me a sec.
You're already dead.
It's okay.
Alright, there we go.
Anyway, like I was saying, TC Kun has been here for how many
years?
20, 21, 22, 23, 25 years.
Sorry, I have to count for my fingers.
This is a problem.
And you've been there since the very beginning.
like anything really started before like you know since I
before I went went like went big in content creation and you
know we've had lots of issues with you PC Koon you know with
we've we you had a lot of surgeries over the years and you
had so many operations some of these parts inside you used
to be from the other pc before you the pc kun senior uh yes
i think that was also an issue guys regarding why pc kun
like fucked up in the way it did and just died like that
because it actually had some parts that went from like even
before his time so so we had some transplants from like his
previous generation so that could have been also a huge
problem um so he was he was a mess going in from the
beginning like i did not i did not like give him like the
pathway to success i was so fucking cheap i like
frankenstein parts together onto him so but despite all of
that You gave us five really good years, PC Kune, for all of
us, from the Bark Knights to the Dragons.
And, like, I mean, PC, he was a winner.
He went through so many tournaments, and he got us that
Seijam Slam to win.
Despite, you know, despite we were going like five frames
per second, we were a fucking winner.
glorious years in that five years during this three-year
mark we thought we thought you were gonna die in that five
in I don't know you guys remembered but in year three year
three of his lifespan we had such a scary surgery that we
had to do do you guys remember that chat where like surgery
at that time you guys remember that and and then you we lay
you to rest um because you had to recover from from that
surgery do you got dragoons do you remember that oh we
thought you
That's my bed!
What do you mean is that a child's bed?
Anyway, in year three, we thought we lost you.
And we took you to the shop for your most scariest surgery.
And we thought we lost you because you wouldn't run
anything.
You crashed all my apex games.
And like, I couldn't boot up Fortnite.
we were so scared but after some after recovery from the
from the from the surgery and like we put in new parts into
you we put in a 4080 we oh wait no that's another surgery
sorry that's a surgery in the future what did we put in we
put a new motherboard in you we got rid of the motherboard
that came from PC Kun senior and we got you a new
motherboard because Yoki has money then and she does now too
but Yoki was making so much money that she can finally
afford better parts for you that you don't need to be
Frankenstein anymore and then you recovered
you got better and we thought you were gonna make it PC Koon
We were We all cheered for you When you came back Israel
Thank you for the 10 gift The ships Thank you Thank you And
We thought you were gonna make it But then But then We
didn't know What you had Was terminal That no amount of
surgeries Was gonna save you But we were all a fool All of
you of us thought that if we kept giving you new parts that
we kept just frankensteining you now you'll just get better
but sadly that was not the case because in another two years
you started failing again
and we couldn't even play fortnite on you anymore We didn't
know what to do.
So we took you back into the hospital.
Back to the repair shop.
We took you back into the repair shop.
He see Koon.
We thought this time.
Maybe.
Maybe the second surgery.
The third or the third.
Also no sorry.
The third surgery.
You went through so many surgeries.
I've lost track.
And they're back to back.
You were in the hospital for a week straight.
You had so many surgeries sent.
We even gave you a 40-80.
We thought you would pull through.
Because when we took you back home after.
We could finally play Fortnite.
And the finals.
We were able to play Fortnite in the finals, but it was just
temporary.
Because whatever you had, it spread again.
It didn't matter how many new parts we gave you, PC Koon.
It didn't matter that you had a 4080.
Whatever that was inside you, it kept coming back.
I was desperate.
I didn't want to let you go.
You've been here for five years, PC Koon.
You were there since the beginning, and you brought me all
the way here.
We had to underclock it.
It was our last shot.
this was the last thing we can do because you kept crashing
you crashed again it was just one crash I thought it was
just a fluke but then you kept crashing even more and then I
got worried I was like it's just game crashes I don't have
to worry about that but then you started blue screening and
then that's when i knew it was only a matter of time and we
didn't have that much left together
i thought maybe the first blue screen it was a fluke you
know pc coon the very first blue screen we had it was a
fluke but then you you blue screen when we were just off
stream was technically like they were streaming and you blue
screened four times in two hours that's when i knew i had to
take you to the barn i had to take you to behind the barn
back to the farm upstate
You were there for a long time, PC cool.
But, sadly, everything has to come to an end.
And I got sent a new free PC.
That might be a little bit better than you.
I'll never say that while you're still alive.
Because technically I have to use you later and like him
tonight.
So you gotta live on just a little bit longer.
So...
Wait, I'm sorry, PC Koon.
This new PC also has a 4080.
And all the parts, all the parts are new.
it's only that I don't have windows activated but I think I
can solve that later but I'm sorry PC Koon you had parts
stemming all the way from PC Koon senior I don't know what's
wrong with you there is no cure the doctors they said you
had one year left to live by extended your lifespan to Five
years, PC Koon.
But it's time.
You just, you lived so long and saw so many victories, so
many achievements.
But there was no cure to keep you on longer.
I can't keep Frankensteining you anymore, PC Koon.
I don't know what is wrong.
I don't know what is wrong, PC Koon.
It's just not curable.
The doctors don't even know.
So we have to put you down.
Thank you for all the years you've given us.
I'll just say, PC Koon.
Just don't think of it, PC Koon, of me like replacing you
with a younger, hotter model.
by choice okay i just need you to know this pc code it's not
by choice that the newer pc happens to be younger and hotter
and more expensive than you it's just it was just handed to
me like why would i say no to free stuff just know it wasn't
by choice
Thank you for all For everything you've done Do the dragoons
have any Final words to say To PC Koon guys The dragoons
have any Final words to give us
Don't worry guys Do you guys have any final words
07 guys Get NTRed It wasn't by choice Guys I told you It
wasn't by choice It was just free It's been a long ride PC
code Now Before Before we give a moment of silence before
before we give a moment of silence to PC Kun
I just would like to say
I would like to say something very important before then it
is that we have a word from our sponsors um so
anyways i don't know if you guys know this but my youtube
speaker is out now and it's actually crazy and oh wait sorry
let me turn off uh let me sorry give me a sec let me change
the song real quick
all right anyway before we yeah i need to have like a more
upbeat song by the way give me a sec all right this is good
all right oh my god guys so uh today if you guys didn't know
today uh the youtube's figure just came out for pre-order
and it's only for like four weeks by the way so like after
the four weeks is over look this video was not cheap after
the um after the the four weeks is over the figure is gone
so make sure the pre-order now uh before it's gone forever
uh this is actually like my very this funeral is sponsored
by you too so it's a uh this is my very first official dokey
figure and i actually have like the prototype with me right
now um and it's really cool they sent it to me for free and
everything so yeah make sure uh it's it's so insane like uh
i checked it and like 500 of you guys already pre-ordered um
after it launched like four hours ago so like thank you guys
thank you dragons for pre-ordering it um and um yeah check
it out i'm so happy uh that we have our first official
figure maybe more many more to come in the future let's hope
cross our fingers and hope that that we can get more more
amazing stuff in the future but yeah huge shout out huge
shout out to to youtube's wait mod where is the ad that you
posted can you repost a link and i'll pin it real quick all
right let me pin this real quick all right all right guys
all right there you go i think that's good all right nice
all right okay anyway back to the back to the funeral uh
PC Koon would have wanted this, Chad.
PC Koon would have wanted it.
I've been happy that I'm, like, making it right now.
Now, before we lower the casket for PC Koon, let us have a
minute of silence.
For everybody.
Let's have a minute of silence for PC Kune and everybody.
Oh.
It's okay.
Now I have a hotter, newer version.
Hey!
Alright.
um I I never guys I guess you guys never expected to uh
expected a PC funeral but here we are don't disrespect him
like that oh my god what a what a day guys what a fucking
day oh yeah we have pc will reading that pc had nothing i
provided everything dark blade thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you oh my god yeah that was basically uh my
day my entire day uh i still have not downloaded uh i still
haven't downloaded like everything yet and like i said mic
settings like because i know i sound different i'm sorry if
i sound i'm sorry if i sound really different guys but i
hope uh i hope that like uh i can fix put it into my regular
settings by tonight and i'm gonna take it i'm obviously
gonna take it to the shop to like add another uh add another
driver to this PC to my hotter newer trophy PC uh who's also
younger who's also younger from a good family too
um sorry install a new get a new drive get a new drive
installed in there get another ssd in there because i don't
like that it has only one ssd i feel like i'm going to be
using a lot of space so uh i'm gonna um i'm gonna uh um get
another ssd added in there just to fix it uh dude that's so
it's a pc like what do you mean what the fuck do you mean
It's literally a PC.
I'm just describing a PC.
And like, I'm trying to like think of what else I need to
do.
I think.
I know like I have to.
Oh yeah yeah yeah yeah.
I need to make sure I like save everything.
Like have all my correct settings and everything to
establish.
But yeah.
I'm definitely gonna unplug this one tomorrow and take it to
the shop.
before uh before my stream tomorrow the train because like
really i just need to install the ssd and everything so like
i'll install i'll push plug back in i'll dig the grave out
and then just plug it in and like i'll go like grave robbing
later tonight or tomorrow morning actually do i grave rob
tomorrow morning or later tonight maybe tomorrow morning so
i'll go grave rob tomorrow morning and like like dig through
the carcass for uh my mic settings the
where where the mic settings and then like you know put it
back into the grave so i can put the mics and then take my
my new gal to the shop so i can uh my new gal wants a gucci
bag and i'm gonna get her that my new pc like my younger uh
more expensive like she's a classy lady okay I need to get
her that Louis Vuitton bag and by Louis Vuitton bag I need
to get her that SSD drive into her system and and get her uh
get her all dolled up and and and I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I took that way too far.
I took that too
but yeah it's been a lot.
I think I only slept four hours today because I've just been
like doing PC setup stuff.
I still can't believe it fit in the hole.
Like the triangle fit in the square hole.
Because that was literally my biggest problem.
And that's why it took so long.
I was stalling for so long because I was trying to figure
out what to do because I was like okay maybe I'll just wait
until I move you know maybe I'll just wait until I move and
then like buy a new desk that can fit this PC and then all
it and then it was only because like I forgot there's a side
opening I forgot you can like put the PC in in the side like
I kept thinking like I have to like Slip it into the
pillars.
But I was like, I can't flip it into the pillars.
It's a triangle.
This hole is a square.
Then I forgot there's literally a giant hole in the side.
That I could slide it in.
And this PC has been in a box for a month.
And then just out there for another month.
Because I literally couldn't do shapes.
Like I couldn't.
I literally couldn't figure out shapes.
And like spatial awareness.
that like it was going to fit it was only because i my my
other piece my pc kun was literally dead like the carcass
was just there in the open uh that i had to try something
look i'm 2d i can't think in 3d chat this is the issue i
can't think in 3d if i'm 2d You can't blame that on me
You can't You can't blame that on me I don't think it's
three-dimensionals Yeah, what a fucking wild ride Well I
think that's really it That's really it We celebrated We
celebrated our new PC And hell the funeral Two in one
special guys I hope you guys enjoyed hanging out with me
today uh uh I had a great time just you know just just to
chat um and uh being uh and having you guys there as my
emotional support dragoons uh during the rough time trying
to set everything up so it was really it's great I had a
great time guys i hope you guys had a well not not i hope
you guys didn't have a great time at the funeral but like i
hope you guys had like a general good time not the funeral
part but like you know the everything else before and after
the funeral uh i'm gonna call it here everybody thank you
all for the akasupas too chat chat i really appreciate it uh
bite size thank you for the akasupa thank you to our real
one he will be a missed shady thank you for the akasupa
thank you thank you for for the memories, PC-Kun.
Thank you, the Akasupa.
I'm thrilled.
Thank you, thank you.
In memoriam for PC-Kun.
But yeah, I told you guys.
I told you guys I'd have the new PC set up before the stream
today.
Yay!
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, pause
your check, get up and move around to get that blood
flowing.
And if you set up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye-bye, guys.
Bye.